you
so now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week and this
week the Food and Drug Administration
approved the first treatment
specifically targeting postpartum
depression it's a condition that can
impact women following childbirth
sometimes even starting during pregnancy
symptoms can include sadness loss of
energy and feelings of guilt and worth
worthlessness here to discuss this and
more is CBS News medical contributor dr.
David agus good morning morning this is
a condition that you can only truly
understand unless you've been through it
tell us about this new drug um so one in
nine women have this condition the
number one cause of death after
childbirth is suicide I mean so this is
a real problem this is a drugs'll Rezo
that's given by intravenous infusion
over 60 hours so you have to be admitted
to a certain hospital there's certain
specified hospitals that can do this you
basically have to leave your child for
60 hours and go for this $34,000 but it
works it's a derivative of a
progesterone a natural hormone that can
very quickly reverse the depression and
then patients can go on to medicine the
standard medicines we have that take
weeks to work the argument is you don't
want to wait weeks with this postpartum
depression you want an immediate and
that's what this drugs did so it's
exciting except it's more common in
people of lower socioeconomic class
exactly who won't be able to afford this
drug so while exciting scientific event
I'm a little bit worried about the
implementation I didn't realize it was
so common and I also didn't know that
there was no treatment really until now
why is that the case and do you think
this will open the door to other
treatments well I think you know we have
drugs that work for depression they just
take a long time to work and this is one
where you need something immediate to
bond with the child to take care of the
child and obviously you know we didn't
have one you know it's always difficult
to develop drugs when you have a woman
who may be breastfeeding when you have
somebody after a condition like
pregnancy and so there's been reticence
to do it now I think there's going to be
a need for an oral one that acts
immediately by the same mechanism and
that's under development now so I think
that'll be the really big advance
because it should be applicable to the
masses all right next up low dose
aspirin for years the small
has been hailed as a preventive measure
for heart attack and stroke but in a
reversal newly updated cardiovascular
health guidelines from the American
College of Cardiology say low-dose
aspirin is not recommended for people
who are in good health and without
certain risk factors David you've done a
lot of research on aspirin what do you
what's your takeaway from he's got it so
this is controversial I have gotten so
many emails this week I'm literally my
inbox is overload every single person
what do i do what do I do
so here is the bottom line the reversal
did not happen in most people right the
study that came out more recently show
that if you were over 70 and had not
been on aspirin and started it and
appeared a follow-up of about five years
no real benefit in heart disease or on
cancer well the cancer benefit we don't
start till sea till around year six and
these people hadn't been on it at the
age we say you should start at which is
earlier so 40 or 50 you have a 10%
chance a risk of significant heart
disease you should be on it if you have
a family history of cancer you should be
on it so myself I have a family history
of heart disease in cancer I am on a
baby aspirin a day that I started at age
40 so in most people the recommendations
haven't changed the big caveat is
aspirin can cause bleeding yeah so if
you have any risk factors for bleeding
you shouldn't be on it but you should
sit down with your doctor and say hey
what's my risk for heart disease cancer
and based on that going this very simple
preventive mechanism that by blocking
inflammation has a dramatic effect on
disease all right finally for many
stroke survivors basic arm movements can
be a real challenge now researchers at
Northwestern University are showing how
gaming might be able to assist a small
group participated in the study playing
a customized video game where specific
muscles controlled the on-screen
movements this sounds promising I love
how there's the can of anw rootbeer
picture that's Chicago this is
tremendous and very exciting is that
they're basically teaching you to
control the muscles in your arm through
video gaming and it worked and so it's a
real hope for people that in some of
these people had had stroke and could
move for a long periods of time and
they regain some function so I think
it's really exciting that they're taking
people with a debilitating condition and
giving them a chance at hope to really
recover some of their functions dr.
David agus thank you so much that is
exciting